[Musique]
avant cette élection il y avait comme un
phénomène de vote qu'on peut appeler
utile c'est-à-dire qu'emmanuel macron
avait dit voter pour moi pour battre le
front national et que le front national
avait dit voter pour moi pour bat
emmanuel macron d'ailleurs c'était un
grand bluff parce que du coup
effectivement le front national est en
tête mais résultats des opérations
emmanuel macron ne va rien changer à sa
politique voir il va la renforcer
donc on voit bien que mais que marine le
pen a menti je suis convaincu que
beaucoup d'électeurs qui ont eu ce
réflexe du vote utile choisiront lors
des élections municipales lors des
élections cantonales lors des élections
régionales les élus républicains qu'ils
connaissent et qu'ils apprécient et je
crois que le scénario sera très
différent pour en marche la lui n'a
aucune implantation territoriale en
termes d'élus peut-être campagne qu'on a
vécu elle a été aussi malgré ce score
elle a été aussi fondatrice on a
vraiment vécu un élan d'abord d'unités
de cette famille politique qui s'est
rassemblée autour de cette campagne et
on a fait une campagne autour d'un
projet autour de propositions
ce qui est certain c'est qu'on a eu
devant nous ce rouleau compresseur une
sorte de duel qu'on avait redouté et
qu'on n'a pas su éviter entre marine le
pen et emmanuel macron et non nous ne
sommes pas morts et que nous comptons
bien pouvoir proposer aux français un
autre projet que celui de voter contre
marine le pen ou contre emmanuel macron
arrêtons de nous tirer dessus nous mêmes
et ce matin aussi ce que je veux faire
c'est lancer un appel un appel au cessez
le feu
je pense que les petites phrases des uns
des autres n'ont absolument aucun sens
il faut se poser alors pourquoi de fond
pourquoi voter cette question avait
débuté pour les lignes 1 et bien d'abord
et apolline de madame parce que on porte
en tout cas j'essaie de le faire moi un
regard lucide sur l'état de la france
chaque jour de cette campagne sur le
terrain j'ai perçu les tensions
profondes qui traverse notre pays nous
ne pouvons laisser la france s'enlise et
dans ce désespoir politique
il y a le front national le
rassemblement national et il y à la
république en marche la république en
marche qui échoue dans la politique
qu'elle mène enfin n'allez pas me dire
que la situation du pays est
satisfaisante d'un point de vue
économique d'un point de vue sécuritaire
ou d'un point de vue
ou sur le sujet de l'immigration et il y
en a en face un parti qui n'apporte pas
de solution mais qui ne fait qu'ajouter
des peurs et fédérer les mécontentements
est ce que c'est ça qu'on veut pour les
prochaines échéances main le devoir de
préparer une vraie force de
réconciliation nationale réconcilier la
france avec elle même réconcilier les
français entre en assumant pleinement
frédéric rivière un espace un espace à
reconstruire élargir l'espace de la
droite et du centre
[Musique]